hey Battle Damage angry nerd here with a
special request please put a robot to
the test these little helper droids were
clearly designed to lull us into
ignoring the robots plan for world
domination but the angry nerd wants the
angry nerd gets you're watching battle
damage here on Battle Damage we test the
durability of technology so while we
trust these rumbas to clean our floors
can we trust them to keep working after
taking a fall now get back here
get back here hit me it seems sturdy
something's gonna break off roll action
now this is the true test I'm not going
to touch anything but the power button
yay it lives it's cleaning itself that's
sad but it works John good better than
the Roomba roll action okay so this kind
of bottom piece haha good some pocket it
was this make a noise okay that is its
death gasp give up Eric it's dead
no you can't save it for our final test
we invited the rumbas mortal enemy the
Viking white of Vikings hate Roombas we
have no idea and yes we know this is
ridiculous Ragna wrong I'm a little
scared
roll action
ready to turn on and definitely made
like a death whimper all right you
killed it remember that you can request
what we battle test next by leaving a
comment down below or on social media
with the hashtag battle damage quick
ticket still alive
vengeance enslave all humans